[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHIP CONLEY: Hi.
Let's start by saying I
apologize for a little bit
of a hoarse throat.
Yeah, you go on a book
tour, and you lose
things, including your voice.
So I'm going to start with
about a 10-minute talk
that I gave two weeks ago at
TED headquarters in New York,
and it goes on the ted.com
website a week from today.
So this is a 10-minute talk.
Then I'll talk a
little bit more about,
what does it mean to
be a modern elder?
What are the qualities of
a what a modern elder--
what are the qualities that
a modern elder exhibits?
And then I'll talk a
little bit about what
I think companies can
do to actually foster
more intergenerational
collaboration and wisdom.
Sound good?
And then we'll do a Q&A.
All right, so it
was my third day
on the job at a hot Silicon
Valley startup in early 2013.
I was more than twice the
age of the dozen engineers
in the room.
I had been brought
into the company,
because I was a seasoned
expert in my field,
but in that particular
room, I felt like a newbie
amongst the tech geniuses.
So I did my best
to be invisible.
And then the 25-year-old wizard,
who was leading the meeting,
turned to me and asked,
if you shipped a feature,
and no one used it,
did it really ship?
Ship a feature?
Whoa, oy vey.
I realized Chip was in
deep shit, because I
had no idea what he
was talking about.
After an awkward
silence, he mercifully
moved on to someone else,
and I slid down in my chair,
and I couldn't wait for
that meeting to end.
That was my introduction to
Airbnb five and 1/2 years ago.
I had been invited by the
three millennial co-founders
to join the company to help
them take this small tech
startup, fast-growing
tech startup,
and turn it into a
global hospitality brand,
but also to be the
in-house mentor for Brian
Chesky, the CEO.
So all that sounded
good, because I'd
spent, from age 26 to 52, being
a boutique hotel entrepreneur,
and I'd amassed a lot of
hospitality knowledge.
But after my first
week at Airbnb,
I realized that the
brave new home-sharing
world didn't need most of my old
school bricks and mortar hotel
insights.
A stark reality rocked me.
What do I have to offer
these young people?
I've never worked
in a tech company.
I'm 52 years old, and I'd
never worked at a tech company
at that point.
I was reporting to someone
21 years younger than me--
Brian.
But I was also
supposed to mentor him.
I was the head of global
hospitality and strategy.
Five and 1/2 years
ago, I had never
heard of the sharing economy,
nor did I have an Uber or Lyft
app on my phone.
This was not my natural habitat.
But I could have gone
off and run for the hills
or made fun or cast judgment
on these young geniuses.
But instead, I decided to
turn judgment into curiosity
and imagine how I could
match my wise eyes
with their fresh eyes.
I sort of imagined myself a--
or fancied myself a
modern Margaret Mead
amongst the millennials, sort
of a cultural anthropologist.
And I quickly learned that
I had as much to offer them
as they did to me.
But the more I thought
about it, the more
I really noticed that we often--
the way we operate as
respective generations,
we often operate almost
like isolated countries
on the same continent.
Yes, we share borders,
but we don't necessarily
trust each other enough
to sometimes share
our respective wisdom.
Looking at the modern
workplace, I've
come to believe that
creating a pipeline
or opening up a pipeline
of intergenerational wisdom
could be the trade agreement
of our time in the workplace.
Almost 40% of us today have a
boss that's younger than us,
and that's only
growing as a number.
Power is cascading, and I
feel silly actually saying
this part of the speech, because
you know it here at Google,
but power is cascading to young
people faster than ever before.
Why?
Because we are growing
in our reliance
on digital intelligence,
what's called DQ.
We have young people starting
companies in their early 20s.
They become global giants
by their 30th birthday.
And yet somehow, we expect
these young, brilliant digital
leaders to miraculously embody
the relationship wisdoms
and leadership skills
we older workers
have had decades to learn.
It's hard to microwave
your leadership skills
and emotional intelligence.
We have ample evidence that
gender and ethnically diverse
teams are often more effective.
But what about age?
It's a really
important question,
and it's one of the
questions I posed
a lot to various companies,
because today, we
unintentionally have five
generations in the workplace
for the very first time.
So maybe it's time to
get a little bit more
intentional about
how we work together.
A number of European
studies have
shown that age-diverse
teams can be more effective,
and yet only 8% of companies
that have a diversity
and inclusion
program have expanded
that program or
strategy to include
age as just as important
of a demographic as, say,
gender or race.
Maybe they didn't get the memo.
The world is getting older.
One paradox of our time is
that baby boomers are healthier
longer, vibrant, and we're
in the workplace longer,
and yet often feeling
less and less relevant.
Some of us feel a little bit
like an old carton of milk
with an expiration date stamped
on our wrinkled foreheads.
For many workers in midlife,
this isn't just a feeling.
It's actually a harsh
reality, if you lose your job,
and the phone stops ringing.
For many of us, we feel
like our experience
might be seen as a liability
more than an asset.
Many of us have heard
the phrase, "60 is
the new 40," physically, right?
Well, when it comes
to Silicon Valley,
and it comes to
the digital world,
and when it comes,
frankly, more and more
to the power in the workplace,
I believe 30 is the new 50.
So if power is moving
10 years younger,
and we're going to live 10
years longer, do the math.
A new 20-year irrelevancy
gap has been created
for those of us in midlife.
Midlife used to be
considered 45 to 65,
but now it's really expanded,
I think, to 35 to 75,
because there's
people, especially
in the Valley, who start feeling
irrelevant in their mid 30s.
And there's lots of people
who are going to work way
past the traditional
retirement age of 65,
and they may work till
75, because if you're
going to live to 100, either
by choice or by necessity,
you may work longer.
So that midlife marathon--
and by the way, as an aside,
the term, "midlife crisis,"
was created in
1965, but we haven't
done much in 53 years since
then to make it any better.
OK, now it starts
getting better.
That's all the depressing stuff.
Here's the good stuff.
Here's a bright spot.
Why is it that as we age,
we become a little wiser
about our humanity?
Our physical peak as
humans is probably our 20s,
or as adults is our 20s.
Our financial peak, salary-wise,
is 45 in Silicon Valley.
For the general population,
it's about 50 to 52.
But our emotional peak actually
happens in midlife and beyond,
because we start to
develop pattern recognition
about ourselves and others.
So how do we actually-- oops--
so the question is,
how do we actually
help companies tap into
that potential midlife
wisdom, while also nurturing
their young, brilliant digital
natives?
I think the most successful
companies today will figure out
how to create a powerful
alchemy between the two.
Here's how the alchemy
worked for me at Airbnb.
I was assigned a sharp
young partner, Laura Hughes,
to be my partner in creating
the hospitality department.
I oversaw about eight
different teams at Airbnb.
Hospitality was one, strategy
was another, et cetera,
but I'll focus on
hospitality for now.
Early on, Laura
Hughes, my partner,
saw that I was a little lost
when it came to technology,
and so she often sat right
next to me at meetings.
And when I heard words
that I didn't understand,
I'd write her a note, and she
would be my tech translator.
She spent four years here at
Google before a year and a half
at Airbnb when I
met her, and she was
27 years old when I met her.
Like many of her
millennial cohorts,
she had been elevated to a
role of being a manager way
before she ever had any
formal leadership training.
I don't care if you're in
the B2B world, the B2C world,
the C2c world, or the A2Z world.
Business and organizations
are fundamentally H2H,
human to human.
And yet, Laura's approach
to leadership and management
had been formed in the
technocratic world.
It was all about accountability
charts and business roadmaps
and metrics and
metrics and metrics.
And that's not bad.
I could get shot if I say that
too loudly here at Google.
Not bad, but it needed to be
dosed with something else.
What she said to me about a
month into the job is like, oh,
my gosh, what I appreciate is
that you help us, as a team,
create a compelling
vision, and then
that becomes the North
Star for how we operate.
And she said, your
fact knowledge chip
isn't all that valuable here.
How many rooms a maid cleans
in an eight-hour shift doesn't
matter in the
home-sharing world,
but your process knowledge
is really valuable,
process knowledge
being you know how
to get things done based upon
understanding the underlying
motivations of
everyone in the room.
And your organizationally
savvy enough,
because you've been
around for a while,
to know how to get things
done in an organization.
So as I spent more
time at Airbnb,
I actually started to notice
that maybe a new kind of elder
was emerging in the workplace.
No, not the elder
of the past, who
was regarded with reverence.
There are only a few
places in the world
where that's still the case.
No, this modern elder
actually was appreciated
for their relevance, their
ability to take timeless wisdom
and apply it to
modern day problems.
Maybe it's time that we
actually start valuing wisdom
as much as we do disruption.
And I absolutely think it's time
we reclaim the word, "elder,"
but give it a modern twist.
The modern elder is
as much an intern
as they are a mentor, because
they realize in a world that
is changing as quickly
as it is today,
that it's important
that our beginner's
mind and catalytic curiosity
allows them to create almost
like a life-affirming elixir
for both themselves and everyone
else.
We're very familiar
with intergen improv
in music and the arts.
Think Tony Bennett and Lady
Gaga or Wynton Marsalis
and the Young Stars of Jazz.
But in the business
world, we don't really
have a language for this,
this kind of riffing off
of each other with
different generations.
But we might often call
it mutual mentorship,
and mutual mentorship
is, frankly--
in my case, I was
getting Millennial DQ,
digital intelligence,
and what I was
offering back was Boomer EQ, but
it could be Gen X EQ as well.
At Airbnb, I actually had a
dose of this kind of intergen
reciprocity when
Laura and I took on,
along with our stellar
data science team,
the process of completely
remaking the Airbnb
peer-to-peer review
system, based
upon Laura's analytical
mind and my sort of more
human-centered intuition.
With this powerful alchemy of
algorithm and people wisdom,
we were able to actually take
a relatively good program,
the peer-to-peer
review system, and make
it a great program that helped
our hosts better understand
the needs of our guests,
such that we actually
got Airbnb's guest satisfaction
level with our hosts
higher than the hotel
industry, substantially higher,
because we used the same
metric the hotel industry does.
So this is a great example of
high tech meeting high touch.
As a modern elder,
I also learned
that I needed to intern
publicly and mentor privately.
What I mean by that
is, like, you know,
nobody wants me telling them
in the middle of the meeting
that they did something wrong.
I'm not their parent.
That's what their
parent might do.
But what they really
appreciated was this.
And let me-- here's my
search engine [INAUDIBLE]..
Search engines are great
for giving us answers,
and over time, you may
actually, at Google,
get better and better at
even posing questions to us.
I don't know where that's going.
I might ask Dan
in the back there.
But the bottom line
is you're great.
Google has all the
knowledge in the world,
and so answers come from
a place like Google.
But a beautifully posed
question asked by a wise elder
can actually unlock
someone's mind and heart
to all kinds of other things.
And so I actually do
believe that a wise elder,
a modern elder can actually
have that finally attuned heart
and mind that can
actually open up
the possibilities for
someone younger than them.
Over time, to my
surprise, I had, actually,
over 100 people in the
organization asking
me to mentor them.
It was not my job, not even
in my scope of work at all.
But every time somebody
asked, I said yes.
It was nuts, to be
honest with you,
but I loved it,
because what happened
is I learned as much from
them as they did from me.
And that was the beauty of it.
In sum, Brian Chesky,
the CEO, asked
me to join Airbnb because
of my industry knowledge.
But what I really offered
was my well-earned wisdom.
Peter Drucker, the
management theorist,
created the phrase or the term,
"knowledge worker," in 1959.
I think it's time we retire
the phrase, "knowledge worker,"
and replaced it with "wisdom
worker," because, really,
that's what we offer
in our humanity.
With five generations in the
workplace for the first time,
we can either operate
like separate isolationist
countries, or we can find
a way to build bridges
across those
generational borders,
so we can learn from people
both older and younger than us
and delight in that.
It's time, also, to switch up
our thinking about the physics
of wisdom, so it's not just
moving from old to young,
but it's moving from
young to old as well.
So in your life,
personally, who could you
reach out to to actually build a
mutual mentorship relationship?
And organizationally,
how do we create
the conditions to foster more
of an intergenerational flow
of wisdom?
This is the new sharing
economy, in my opinion.
So that's my talk.
There you go.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, thank you.
So let me talk for
a few more minutes,
and then we'll open
up for questions.
The idea of a
modern elder really
made me sick the
first time I heard it.
Someone said, you're
like my elder.
I was like, you know,
what did I do wrong?
Because "elder"
sounded like "elderly."
And of course, here's the
thing is 50 years ago,
"elder" was elderly.
50 years ago, the average age
of when someone actually went
into a nursing home was 65.
Today, it's almost 85.
So we have actually created
a new period of life.
Longevity in the US in the
year 1900 was 47 years old.
By the year 2000,
it was 77 years old.
We added three decades
to US average longevity
in one century, but
we have done zero
to actually define this
period of life that
is pre-elderly and midlife
and a little bit later.
I'm 58 this month.
I'm absolutely right
in the middle of it.
But as I said
earlier, I actually
think there's a lot of
people in the middle of it
in the sense that when
you have, especially
in Silicon Valley, a growing,
young population of people who
are very smart, being
able to figure out,
how do you match that smart,
young talent with people
older, who might be able to
actually offer something, is,
I think, one of the most
interesting HR and leadership
opportunities of the 21st
century in the workplace.
What I'll say is that the book--
I think you're all
getting books, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, maybe?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
We've got a few copies left.
CHIP CONLEY: OK, there's
a few copies left.
OK.
Hopefully, you're
going to get a book.
And what you'll see is there
are four lessons in the book,
and I'll just go through
this really quickly,
and then I'll finish with just
one organizational thought,
because I think
Google actually is
a role model for the
organizational thought.
So the four lessons I learned
was, number one, evolve.
If you're in midlife--
and I'm defining
midlife 35 to 75--
it's a wide definition--
the number one
thing you need to be
able to do to be able to
rewire yourself and reframe
your mastery is to evolve.
And "evolve" basically
means you actually
need to be willing
to actually shed
part of your historic identity
and your historical knowledge.
It doesn't mean it
goes away forever.
It just means you don't
show up with that.
I was the CEO of my own boutique
hotel company, as Karen said,
Joie de Vivre.
And we created 52 boutique
hotels, a few of them
down here.
Actually, we were the biggest
hotelier in Silicon Valley
and San Francisco
or the Bay Area.
So I was a CEO for 24
years, took a company
from one to 3,500 employees.
I sold it.
I had a couple years
off, and then I
was like, OK, what
am I doing next?
And then Brian
Chesky approached me.
If I had gone into that job
thinking of myself as the CEO,
it wouldn't have worked.
Brian and I were lucky
enough, two nights ago,
to be on stage at the
Marines Memorial Theater
with 500 people in the
audience giving a talk,
together, Brian and me, to
saying, how did this work?
How did a millennial
and a modern elder
come together to help
create a business
plan that was able to flourish?
So part of it was me
being willing to say,
I used to be the
sage on the stage,
and now I'm the
guide on the side.
And what that meant is I
had to right size my ego.
I needed to realize that
the last thing Brian needed,
as a leader 21 years
younger than me,
was having me, in meetings,
say things that he
should be doing differently.
Obviously, that needed to
be the mentoring privately.
But more than anything,
I need to also evolve
my knowledge, which has brought
me to the second lesson, which
is to learn.
So a lot of times, people
in midlife need to evolve,
but then they actually have
to say, I'm willing to learn.
I'm going to be a
lifelong learner.
I'm going to learn more now in
my 50s than I did in my 40s.
Now that breaks
conventional wisdom.
There's an element that we
think, OK, as you get older,
you just have less to learn,
partly because it's almost
thought that you have a
bottle , and it's full.
I don't have anymore space.
There's no more space to
put more knowledge in it,
and that's--
in terms of how our brains
work, that's not how it works.
So sometimes you have to pour
out a little bit also in order
to make some extra room.
So learning is a really
key part of that,
and that's chapter
5 in the book.
And the third lesson I
learned was collaboration.
And one of the things
that's so interesting--
I love-- in the book, I do talk
about Project Aristotle, which
was the collaboration
project here,
or the study of what
makes successful teams
and effective teams.
Interesting thing just to
look at-- that collaboration
is so essential.
And yet in-- when
I joined Airbnb,
one thing that was most
noticeable-- we were--
Karen and I were just talking
about meetings and studying
meetings, what works
and what doesn't.
Oh, my gosh.
The meetings at Airbnb
were really, really hard
to sit through, because they
weren't really well-organized,
and there was not a
collaborative spirit.
There's a lot of evidence and
studies that's shown that,
frankly, put a couple
of women in the room,
and put a couple older
people in the room,
and it tends to lead
to-- not always--
to a more collaborative team.
And it's partly because
there's a little more empathy.
Oh, she's laughing.
OK.
Do you agree?
Yes?
And I think what we need to
know about that is collaboration
is essential for any company.
And so one of the
things that I really
heartily recommend to
people who are in midlife
and remake themselves is to
really speak to, how are they--
how do they use their
EQ, which can grow
with time, in a way that
actually shows that they have
collaboration skills?
And then the fourth
lesson is counsel,
and that's actually the lesson
that most people go to first.
You're older, and you
still feel like, well, I'm
here to advise people.
I'm here to mentor people.
And honestly, if that's what
you're going to lead with,
and you haven't done
the other three first,
people will maybe think
that you're either
their preacher or their
parent, because you're going
to actually maybe be lecturing.
And there's a
beautiful old phrase--
"knowledge speaks,
and wisdom listens."
And one of the things that
a lot of people don't know,
and I only learned
two months ago,
is that the owl is
perceived as the wisest bird
or animal in the forest.
Why?
Because it has the most finely
attuned sense of hearing.
So wisdom is about
listening, and it's
about listening not just to
the story, but for the story.
And the difference is for the
story gets beyond the literal.
It allows you to
actually see, what
are the common threads that
you're hearing from the person?
In sum, because I started
writing this book,
and I started feeling like, wow.
I started
interviewing-- my story
is unusual, because I was
asked by the founders at age 52
to join them.
Most people at 52 are
not asked to join a tech
company if they've never
have been in a tech community
before.
So I'm lucky.
I went out, and I
interviewed 150 other people
and said, tell me
what your experience--
most of the people in
their 40s and 50s--
about being in midlife.
And I heard a lot of
anxiety and bewilderment.
And I had a lot of people
saying, you know what?
I don't know how to
get through this time.
And I started thinking about
it, and I said, man, you
know what's interesting is we
as a society have historically
helped people through
transitional times
by creating rituals
or celebrations.
Like with puberty,
it's bat mitzvah,
bar mitzvah, quinceanera.
You're going to go from
adolescence to adulthood-- you
have a commencement ceremony.
You graduate from something.
You actually are
going to get married.
You have a wedding.
You're going to have a baby.
You have a baby shower.
You're going to die.
You have a funeral.
But between baby shower
and funeral, nada, nothing.
And back when the
longevity was 47,
it didn't matter,
because midlife was 24.
But midlife today is, who knows?
Somewhere around 50, 55 maybe.
Who knows?
And we have nothing to
address the transitions that
happen in midlife.
What are those transitions?
Well, you know, you
can lose a parent.
You could lose a spouse.
You could actually get divorced.
You can change job or
career or location.
You can actually go through
empty nester syndrome,
where the kids are gone.
You go through menopause.
Men, we go through andropause.
You don't even
know what that is.
I'm going through it.
All these things
happen, and there's
no transitional support.
So long story short is I created
something called the Modern
Elder Academy.
I finally totally
embraced the word.
Not only was it the
subtitle of the book,
but I said, you know what?
Modern elder-- I'll
be one of those,
and let's create an academy.
So we did in Baja,
California, so in Mexico,
just one hour north
of Cabo San Lucas.
It's a three-acre
campus on the beach,
and we have people coming
from all over the world.
We did a beta program of it
the first half of the year.
153 people went
through week-long
and two-week long programs
that went really well.
And 50% of the people
are on scholarship,
so it's a social enterprise.
It's not-- it's not--
the purpose of it is
not to make money.
Last thought, before we
open up for questions--
organizationally,
what can we do to help
foster more intergenerational
collaboration or more
understanding of the
value of the modern elder?
Two thoughts-- number one is one
thought is to start with, OK,
if you have new hire
buddies in the company,
consider how you actually match
people who don't look much
alike--
not gender, race,
age, et cetera.
How do you help to
foster that, even
in the early days of
someone joining a company?
But the bigger idea I
have that really speak--
and I have a bunch of ideas.
Chapter 9 in the book
is full of 10 ideas
that companies actually
could incorporate.
But the one that relates
to Google is this.
I know you have
20% time, which was
supposed to be 80% plus 20%.
It's really 100%
plus 20%, right?
So the idea was, at Google,
engineers, especially who
wanted to go out and
innovate, could actually
be given the opportunity to
work on innovation projects that
might serve the company.
Great idea.
What if we actually got a
little bit more intentional
about asking questions on
employee surveys, questions
like the following--
other than your boss or
someone on your team,
who in the company do you look
to for advice or for wisdom?
What if we could actually
start identifying
not just the spaces of
innovation in the company,
but the spaces of wisdom and
who actually are perceived
as the role models for that?
And then what if we actually,
knowing that information,
started to develop
programs where
people who have institutional
wisdom and knowledge,
have been in the company for--
you pick the determining
amount of years.
At Procter and Gamble,
there is a program
called the Mastery Program.
It's 10 years.
But at a tech company,
it might be five years.
Once a person has
been there that long,
you have the ability,
if you choose to,
to start moving into the modern
elder or the mastery program,
which allows you to actually
scope down a little bit what
you're working on and actually
allocate some of your time
to things that would be
helpful to the company
around institutionalized wisdom.
Could be in-house mentorship,
but in many cases,
it could be actually
sitting-- and the way
Procter and Gamble does it, you
actually go sit in on teams,
and you actually
get joint teams,
because if you have
collaboration skills,
and if you have
institutionalized wisdom
about how Procter and
Gamble has innovated,
you actually offer
that to the teams.
So it's just an idea,
because I really think that--
frankly, if Brian said to me,
knowing that there were 100
people that I was
mentoring over the course--
not all at the same time, but
over the five and 1/2 years
I've been there--
if Brian knew how much
time that was taking,
and he knew I could
actually somehow scope down
my primary responsibilities
so that I could spend either
20% or maybe 50% my time
on just helping create
that invisible productivity,
which a modern elder can
provide, because there's
a lot of evidence
that if you are doing
this well, you're
not just productive yourself.
You're making other people and
teams more productive as well.
If I could have done that,
I probably wouldn't have,
on my four-year
anniversary, said,
Brian, I need to move to
a strategic advisor role,
because this is just too much.
So with that, I'm now
going to open it up
to questions from
you or from Dory.
And let's see what you have.
Questions or comments.
AUDIENCE: First off, thank
you, Chip, for coming.
CHIP CONLEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think that
everyone, regardless of age,
benefits a lot from hearing
about your experiences.
So I'm curious if you're
willing or able to share some
of the advice that you gave
Brian Chesky, like some
of those private one-on-ones
or public meetings.
CHIP CONLEY: Well, I mean that's
a big, general-- first of all,
Mike, thanks for the question.
And that's a big question,
because it'd really
depend on context.
I'd suggest-- I'll
answer the question,
but I'm going to suggest
something to you.
Just this afternoon, the
Commonwealth Club put online--
I know it's online, because
I saw it on Twitter--
put online our Commonwealth
Club talk from two nights ago.
Honestly, that
Commonwealth Club talk
was almost like being a fly
in the room of Chip and Brian.
So Brian would come over to
my house almost every weekend,
and I have a cottage
in the backyard.
And we would do
long meetings there,
because during the
week, what we found
is it was really hard for us to
have substantial time together,
because both of us
were pulled in too
many different directions.
So the Commonwealth
Club talk speaks
to all of that-- what
you're asking about.
So let me say, some--
so if you really are
interested, watch it.
It's an hour talk.
I would say some of the advice
I gave him was the following.
One piece was this.
We spend the first half
of our life accumulating,
and we spend the second
half of our life editing.
That's my point of view.
And what I mean by
that is you often
see it with people
with their homes.
The kids leave, and then,
OK, you want to downsize.
You see it with people
sometimes with their friends
and their interests.
They actually want to get more
focused on certain things,
because we have stuff,
and we have knowledge,
and we have all of these
different responsibilities,
and then around 45 or 50,
we say, this is too much.
I need to edit it down.
That editing capability
is really valuable
when someone younger,
who has a lot of options,
is able to prioritize.
One of the things I
think helped Brian with
was when I joined the
company in early 2013,
we had 30 strategic initiatives.
No one in the company,
including Brian,
could recite the 30
strategic initiatives.
So I led our off-sites.
Whenever we did off-sites with
the senior leadership team,
I usually led those.
And so our second one
that I led was in New York
in September of 2013.
And we had 23
strategic initiatives
we were going to have for 2014.
It was sort of nice.
I said, OK, let's alph--
put a dozen on the
leadership team.
Let's come together
and make the decision
of what are the four that
we're going to actually bet on
for next year.
And let's focus on
those, and let's make
sure everybody in the company
knows those are the four,
and then we have regular
opportunities for people
to understand how each
of the four are doing.
It's so simple,
but honestly, when
you're in the midst of a
company that's growing and more
than doubling in
size every year,
you end up doubling the
number of initiatives.
So I think prioritization
and editing
were particularly essential
in my involvement with Brian.
I think another one
was helping Brian
understand that the
level of stamina
that he has as a leader--
he's a big-- he's just--
he's a short but stout
and very muscular
guy who sort of
powers through things.
And not everyone's like Brian.
And I think-- I'll
never forget--
I think it was the
first Thanksgiving
I was in the company, and
the senior leadership team--
we've been working,
like, 70, 80 hour weeks.
And I said to Brian,
like make sure
that no one talked to each
other over Thanksgiving.
But also, on Wednesday,
before Thanksgiving
happens, the day
before Thanksgiving,
I want you to send
wine, flowers,
whatever to the spouses
and families of everybody
who's on the leadership
team, because they're
the ones who are
at home saying, why
the hell did you take this job?
And so that kind of thinking,
that kind of thinking of like,
OK, it's not just
how we mellow--
like we're the collateral
damage in a family when
people are working this hard.
So those are a couple
of simple things,
but I would tell you that
Commonwealth Club-- man,
the moderator was a
woman, Julie Hanna.
She's an Egyptian
technologist, and she's
the executive chair of Kiva,
and, oh, she did a great job.
She did a really great
job of pulling it out
from Brian and me, so.
AUDIENCE: What is the
Commonwealth Club?
CHIP CONLEY:
Commonwealth Club's a--
it's a 115-year-old club
in San Francisco that
brings thought leaders from
around the world to come give
speeches and things like that.
So yeah.
Thanks.
Great question.
Who else?
KAREN: We can use
a Dory question,
and then we'll
come back to live.
So there is a
question that says,
"With the arrival of
several young founders,
the culture of Silicon Valley
changed in the 21st century.
Only technical intelligence
seemingly mattered,
yet the simple wisdom to
ask, why are we doing this,
can save a company millions.
How do we get our
leaders to understand
the value of wisdom?"
CHIP CONLEY: Wow.
What's this person's name?
AUDIENCE: It's anonymous.
CHIP CONLEY: Anonymous.
I love it.
There's so many people with
that name here at Google.
No, I'm kidding.
So what I love about
your question, Anonymous,
is you asked a "why" question.
One of the things I learned in
my five and 1/2 years at Airbnb
is that most of the time,
senior leaders and companies
ask "what" and "how" questions,
which are optimization
questions, whereas
"why" and "what if"
are bigger, almost
existential questions.
They're, frankly, very
inefficient questions,
because they actually require
a bigger, broader answer.
And so they're not
all that well-liked
when they come up in
a meeting, but that's
what the questions I asked.
I asked a lot of "why"
and "what if" questions,
which is, I think,
really valuable,
because being able to ask these
sort of formative questions
that might sound
naive, once I realized
I was an intern as much as I was
a mentor, and I was a learner,
I could feel comfortable asking
sometimes naive questions.
So what I would say to the--
I think that--
Joe Gebbia and I--
who's the co-founder--
we did a fireside chat
yesterday at Airbnb.
And one of the things
we talked about
was the fact that there's almost
a balancing act for companies
that grow fast between
scale and soul.
And that scale and sole
kind of balancing act
speaks to the scale piece
being very quantifiably
driven and, often, very much
about what can be proven.
And the soul piece,
being very intangible,
often very human-centric,
and, often, more intuitive--
and to me, the best
companies who get it right
figure out what's the right
alchemy of scale and soul
to actually--
to shoot for in the future.
And I think the thing
that I said within Airbnb,
and I tried to lead at Joie
de Vivre, my own company,
although, frankly, in a bricks
and mortar boutique hotel
company, we grew
fast, but I mean
you don't grow like a global
giant like Google or Airbnb.
We said, what is it that we
want this company to look
like five years from now
in terms of scale and soul?
And tangibly, what
does that mean?
And then how do
we work backwards?
And how do we actually have
people in the company who
are the role models for both?
I mean the person who actually
has both within them--
great.
And those people are--
the left can do the left
brain-right brain tango.
But the person who is
actually right here
and the person who's right
here-- how do we make sure
they're on teams together?
And how do we actually look at
teams for cognitive diversity?
Not just the demographic
diversity-- yes,
that's important-- but
cognitive diversity
is a really important
part of how do
you help group think not occur.
And so that's a long-winded
answer, but I hope that helps.
AUDIENCE: So we're at Google.
You were at Airbnb.
We've talked a lot
about Silicon Valley.
I'm wondering how you
would generalize this
to the rest of the country,
the rest of the world,
and how that might be different.
CHIP CONLEY: Well, here's the
thing, because people sometimes
say, well, this is
just your Airb--
this is just your technology,
Silicon Valley bubble.
And I was like, you know what?
Seven of the 10 most valuable
companies in the world today
are tech companies.
All companies want
to be tech companies.
I mean I was at
Procter and Gamble
two months ago in their
headquarters, spent
three days with the CEO, senior
team, did a bunch of things
there.
Procter and Gamble wants
to be a tech company.
And what I mean by this
is what's going on here
and what goes on
in the tech world
and what goes on in terms of
showing value, what companies
actually create value,
frankly, in the stock market
is what all those
other companies
want to actually imitate.
So what I want to say is--
and you see you it,
sometimes, in mistakes.
Ford Motor Company
hired a 34-year-old CMO.
Nothing wrong with hiring
a 34-year-old CMO, if they
could actually do the job well.
The person lasted about
a year and a half,
and they didn't work out well.
But someone else could have.
But the question is, when we're
making decisions about leaders,
are we making sure we're
asking enough questions
about their skill set beyond
what they're the expert at?
Somebody could be an expert
at something particular,
and then they grow, because
they're so good at that,
and they don't have the
balance of the other skills
to actually pull off growing
in leadership like they do.
So I would just say, I think
to answer your question,
I think that Silicon Valley
is the model for a lot
of other companies out there.
Is it true that there's
lots of old school companies
that don't fit this?
Yes.
I was on a webinar this
morning, and someone
from a manufacturing company
from Kansas was on the phone.
And it was 200 people
in the company,
and the company he
described is a company that
felt like it's 50 years ago.
And it might work
fine in manufacturing.
They've just started to think
about robotics in this company.
A lot of companies started
to think about robotics
30 years ago.
But it seems to work for them.
But that small company
in Kansas is not
the role model for a
lot of other companies
around the world.
So I think how we do
things here, we need to--
the more you know
your role model--
it's like being a parent--
the more you actually have
to watch your behavior.
So.
AUDIENCE: If I might
add another question.
CHIP CONLEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For you
transitioning from being
CEO to being a mentor-intern,
what are some areas that you
needed to grow that you
found yourself saying, wow,
this is different?
I maybe-- just some thoughts
on what you needed to improve
or what surprised you.
CHIP CONLEY: Two things
I've already said,
and then I'll say others.
One is my ego, just
right-sizing my ego,
realizing that it was time for
me to actually focus on being
not interesting but interested.
And so I was very interested
in how I supported them,
so that was one.
A second thing-- the
idea of being a learner
and the idea of,
OK, I'm in my 50s.
Maybe-- what is it?
What would happen
if, in my 50s, I'm
having my biggest
decade of learning?
That was it as well.
But I think beyond
that, I think one
of the things that happens
with our brains as we get older
is, yes--
is true.
Our recall is not as
good as it used to be,
so memory and
quickness goes away.
But one thing that a
lot of people don't know
is as your brain ages, you
start getting all wheel drive.
All wheel drive
means you actually
do the left brain-right
brain tango more easily.
What does that mean?
It means you actually
are able to move
amongst your whole
brain more quickly
and adeptly than when
you were younger,
when you were more focused.
OK, what is that?
What's the benefit of that?
In a company, the
benefit is it means
it gives you holistic, systemic
thinking that allows you
to get the gist of something.
So what I started to see
at Airbnb and with my "why"
and "what if" questions was,
OK, I'm hearing something here.
I'm not sure everybody else is
seeing the pattern recognition
that I'm seeing.
And therefore, I'm not
listening for the precision
of that particular thing.
There are a lot of other people
in the room who will do that.
I'm actually looking for
the holistic questions.
And so that was a shift for me.
I was a pre--
I was very-- I was
focused on transformation
at my old company.
But I became more and more of
a sort of bigger thinker, which
can be dangerous if you're
just the bigger thinker,
and you're not able to
give solutions as well.
But I think that that
shift into that sort of--
the Socrates role, as
one person said to me.
Like you become a Socrates
talking to the p--
you know, walking
through Athens,
or he was in Greece, right?
Yeah.
So you're asking really
interesting questions.
And I think that
was a shift for me,
because, actually,
when I was younger,
I wanted to be the smartest
person in the room,
and, therefore, I actually
tried to be the fastest
to answer the questions.
And that's what I would do.
And actually, I wasn't doing
that at Airbnb as much, so.
AUDIENCE: I have one question.
Regarding retirement,
what's your take
on knowing we're living longer
with a third third of life
and wanting to do more, as we've
learned, and we're in our 50s
and growing that way?
Do you think that we need
to be rethinking retirement
on the individual
level, or is it
something more systemic to
have companies changing out
into a bigger movement?
What's your take?
CHIP CONLEY: Lots of
thoughts are there.
Thank you, Rachel.
So first of all, the way we've
defined life, historically,
is learn, earn, retire.
Typically, learn until you're
25, earn until you're 65,
and then retire until you die.
That's the model
that I grew up with.
If you're younger than 40
today, you might look at that
and say, no way.
That's not my model.
And it's true.
Young people have a whole
different perspective
on their lives,
partly because they
know they're going
to live longer,
partly because
they're not climbing
corporate ladders like we did.
And it's all good.
I would just say,
for younger people,
you've got the right thinking,
because there's also something
called the U-curve of happiness,
which is when people actually
are least happy in life,
which is, typically--
sorry to say for you
people in your 40s--
it's in your 40s.
But the less you actually
are locked into doing things
that you didn't
necessarily want to do,
because it was just
the conventional path,
the less likely you have
disappointment in your 40s.
So what does all that mean?
It means thinking of
your life as a portfolio
and being able to
curate your own life
and being a little bit
of a freelancer of how
you think about it and
knowing that you're going to--
you might take a year
off, do a sabbatical
in your 40s or your 30s,
or you might go back
to school in your 50s.
All of that is on the table
today, and all of that's
good, because what I
think we're going to see
is more and more people in
their 70s in the workplace.
And that may sound weird.
Like, the person who
checked me in at my hotel
was a 75-year-old.
You know, we're going
to see more of that.
Especially in this country
if our employment situation
is at what it is, and
immigration doesn't open
up much, we are going to have
a necessity to actually find
new sources of employees.
What does that
mean for companies?
I think what it
means for companies
is more and more companies need
to respect the fact that when
people want to actually
start winding down,
they don't want to just be on
the conveyor belt to a cliff.
I was 100% an
employee last week,
and this week, I'm 0%,
because I've retired.
There's a lot of evidence that
shows that when people retire,
their health conditions
actually don't get better.
They actually get worse.
And there's a lot
of reasons for that.
So what do I think that means?
I think the idea of people
moving from five days
a week to three days a week,
and maybe then two days
a week over the course
of three or four years
is something for
companies to consider.
Additionally,
especially for those
people who have great
institutional wisdom,
because that
institutional wisdom--
I mean that's my
role at Airbnb now.
I'm an old timer at Airbnb
not because of my age,
but because I was the 350th
employee in that company that
now has 5,000 employees
five and 1/2 years later.
And only 100 of the 350 are
still there, so the fact
that I'm a strategic advisor,
and when I come to the office,
I am pulled in
different directions,
because the people know I
have a little bit of awareness
of how that works
or this works is
a good thing for the company.
So thanks for the question.
KAREN: Chip, there's another
question in the Dory,
though it's an observation.
I want to read the
observation, and then
ask a question about it.
CHIP CONLEY: Yes.
KAREN: And then we'll go
back to live questions.
So the observation is, "You're
making some assumptions
based on your own experience.
Older people at Google are
probably quite technical.
If we weren't, we
wouldn't be here.
CHIP CONLEY: Yeah, agreed.
KAREN: And so the
question I would
follow that observation with--
I think it's a fair observation,
obviously-- but the question
I would follow that
with is, in your case,
you were able to, in a sense,
use the trade with Laura,
where she taught you technical
competence and language,
and you were able to kind of
trade that for your wisdom
and experience.
If you come in with
a more equivalent
technical groundwork,
in a sense,
you don't have that
trade to offer.
CHIP CONLEY: Well,
it's not as obvious.
KAREN: Yeah, it's
not as obvious.
So how do you--
what would you say
in response to that
in terms of looking
for other ways
to establish that kind
of mutual relationship?
CHIP CONLEY: I'm so glad
someone called me out on it.
Let's just start by saying, yes.
I'm talking in generalities here
and in the average population
as well.
I loved-- I was at a
summit series event
in Utah speaking
about wisdom, and here
was Kevin Kelly, co-founder
of "Wired" magazine,
66 years old, talking to a
bunch of, generally, people
in their 20s and 30s about
the future of technology.
And then right after him was a
guy named Ryan Holliday onstage
who has written a lot
of books about wisdom.
So it was the 31-year-old
talking about wisdom
and the 66-year-old
talking about technology.
So let's be clear, this
is not across the board.
Everybody doesn't
fit this profile.
I think the bigger question is--
that you ask, Karen--
is, how do you
figure out what it
is you have to offer
or what it is that you're
looking for from someone else?
And I think the
subtleties of that
so often have to do with
what you see in a meeting.
It literally could be somebody
who runs a great meeting,
and so this is not
an EQ for DQ thing.
It's just like, that person
runs a great meeting,
and I have a hard
time running meetings.
I'm just going to
see if they want
to have some coffee
and just talk with them
about, what are their four or
five best practices for running
a meeting?
Or it could be something else.
I mean the specifics
of it aren't important.
What's relevant
is the willingness
to go and ask
someone else if they
could give you some tutelage.
And I think the more we create
the culture in companies, where
people feel like that's OK, and
the idea of mutual mentorship
might grow out of that,
that's all we can ask for.
AUDIENCE: Tribal knowledge
versus institutional wisdom--
when you said, "institutional
wisdom," I heard
tribal knowledge and--
CHIP CONLEY: Did you
say "tribal" or--
AUDIENCE: Tribal.
Tribal.
CHIP CONLEY: Tribal, OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just the modalities.
You keep talking
about mutual meeting
face-to-face, mutual
collaboration,
mentorship kind of arrangement.
How about the other
modalities of-- like,
we talk about
knowledge transferred
teaching seminars versus
writing documents and things.
What has your experience
been of the balance
of getting wisdom
effectively communicated
through other forms
than just face-to-face?
CHIP CONLEY: You know,
we live in an era
where you better have other
forms available to you,
for sure.
I mean I think the--
a few years ago, after
I sold my company,
I created a company
called Fest300, Fest300.
And the whole company was
based upon the 300 best
festivals in the world.
And so I went around to some
of the world's best festivals,
because what I believed is
that in the era of URLs,
that IRL experiences, in
real life experiences,
had something to teach us.
So you have to acknowledge
that my bias is
quite strongly the IRL
experience of in real life.
And part of the
reason for that is
because there's the kinds of--
our mirror neurons
work differently
when we're face to face with
someone than, literally,
when we have a screen, and
we're doing a video call.
So I think that there's that.
There's also just the sense
that you can see subtleties
more easily in conversation,
when it's face-to-face.
But let me say,
at the same time,
that I think the technology
around how you understand
who you're talking to and
what the experience is,
is probably so early
stage at this point,
such that 10 years
from now, the ability
to have your mirror
neurons kicked
in more when you're talking
to someone when it's
with a screen may be better.
And there's no doubt the
scaling piece of this,
if you're just talking
about one-on-one stuff, that
doesn't scale very well.
So the process of
educating people
in sort of a more webinar
kind of a format--
that's fine.
I think the key on
everything, all of this,
is about helping
people to understand,
what are their best
learning modalities.
And we aren't taught
that in high school.
We're not taught, are
we a visual thinker?
Or what's the form of learning
that actually is best for us?
If we could help people
understand that earlier,
then I would say that the
question would be easier
to answer, because
then you'd help people,
steer them to that modality
that works best for them.
So thank you.
With that, that's
our hour together.
So thanks to--
KAREN: Thank you, Chip--
CHIP CONLEY: --all of you and
all of you out there watching.
[APPLAUSE]